ad freeze is a renowned theoretical
physicist a professor of physics at the
University of Texas at Austin and a
member of the Simon Observatory she's
one of the most acclaimed scientists of
our time and she's recently made
headlines again claiming to have found
the first evidence of dark stars putting
us one step closer to figuring out what
the universe is made of join us for a
sip of Katie's intoxicating Cosmic
cocktail cosmetology meets cos ology
today's a special episode for me it's
not all the time I get to interview not
only one of my friends not only one of
my collaborators but one of the most
renowned scientists that uh exists today
and that's uh Professor Katie Freeze of
the University of Texas at Austin
welcome Katie how are you enjoying San
Diego thank you Brian I'm having a great
time it's always great to see you it's
great to have you back for your second
uh second appearance on the podcast the
first time you were on was for this just
amazing book I mean there aren't too
many books that you know I read cover to
cover in science because a lot of it I
mean you and I are experts in science so
we don't really need to know much of the
scientific content but this was so much
fun I read the whole thing and I I
really devoured it and digested it and
we're going to get into the hinks of it
uh maybe as a recap for people that
haven't seen it I might uh re-release or
link to the episode uh when Katie was on
two years ago it's amazing but it's
pertinent today we have now Simon's
Observatory branded merch uh which you
can get for $100 million or so this is a
bottle of whiskey for your next uh for
your next Cosmic cocktail Katie that's
hard to say and since um since you were
last on a lot has happened to the
Simon's Observatory and uh for your in
your career and we're going to talk
about all that including this
mesmerizing misdefined concept called
dark stars which may have been detected
we'll talk about that with this device
that's up front right there the James
web Space Telescope student 3D printed
it but first let's let's start with uh
big news sad news in a way uh about a
year and a half ago you tried to connect
me with Professor Steven Weinberg and
since then he uh he passed away he
actually gave a lecture of the same kind
of honorary lecture that you're giving
here uh Dash and Memorial he did it
remotely because it was near the end of
his life uh but you're here in person
very much alive uh talk to us briefly
about Stephen what did he mean to you
what is that what is it like being the
director of the Weinberg ins is the
Weinberg Institute or what do we call it
it is yes it's the Weinberg Institute
for theoretical physics and it is in
honor of Steve Weinberg who was the
greatest physicist of our time there's
just no question I think pretty much
everybody agrees so he he was the
theorist behind much of the standard
model of particle physics the quarks and
leptons and how they merge together
especially going to higher energies and
back in the early Universe the forces of
nature unify together the electro week
Theory and uh can I also say he was a
friend yeah one of the kindest people on
this planet he was wonderful he was as
they say a mench um he uh was one of the
few nobelists that I have not didn't get
a chance to interview sadly will never
get to I had his colorat Shelley glashow
on and they were basically in a friendly
competition since they were in high
school together uh it's just amaz
that's right all the way up to Cornell
and Harvard and their their careers were
so intimately intermeshed and Shelly
thank God is still very much um alive
and with us and sharp as attack uh but I
wonder you know what Stephen might make
of you know some of the discoveries that
have happened just in the last couple of
years um and and in particular things
that we are partnering on with the Simon
Observatory to try to uncover you from a
theoretical angle and myself and my team
from experimental angle and then kind of
com meshing them together so is the um
is is is it not the case that we know
now that we know less about certain
things in the universe including dark
matter and uh especially this Hubble
tension I've been just dying to ask you
about that so where do you come down the
Hubble tension what's the answer because
I I Look to You for for for you know the
the most aidite advice on these matters
so Katie tell us what is your take on
the Hubble tension is it for real should
we just ignore it is it a fad what do
you make of it well I think I think it's
really important so the the trying to
learn about the expansion rate of the
Universe from data from the cosmic mic
background which comes pretty early in
the history of the universe or from
supern noi that are more recent and it
seems that there these numbers are
discrepant at 5 Sigma at this point so
the Hubble constant in based on this
earlier epic is lower than the Hubble
constant 67 versus 72 now putting it in
a broader historical perspective when I
was in grad school there was the camp
that said it's 50 and the other camp
that said it's 100 and so now we're
arguing about 67 versus 72 so is it
possible that there's something going on
in the on the experimental observational
side that will resolve and everything
will meet I don't know Wendy fredman
seems to think so so I don't know is it
is it an observational problem in the
meantime as theorists we get to have fun
trying to explain this when I think
about Katy freeze I think about your
taste and you have exceptional judgment
and taste and you're always seeming to
be you know where the puck is going uh I
had Adam ree in that very chair about
five months ago when he gave a
distinguished lecture much of the kind
that we're looking forward to you uh
you're giving later on today and you
know there's a notion that you know
maybe there are a thousand flowers that
can bloom theoretically but from an
observer's point of view they seem to
get really entrenched in different
explanations and I spoke to your you
know friend Mike Turner recently the
episode hasn't aired yet but but by the
time this one does it might and we
talked about um well what are the known
known about things like the Hubble
tension so not exotic things like
magnetic fields we know magnetic fields
exist do you have a favorite explanation
or is that kind of a non-scientific way
to think about it like should we have
favorite explanations should we be
married to our ideas about theoretical
models that could explain it or should
we just be open and you know kind of see
what happens so I I always my attitude
is always we should be open to see what
happens but there's a lot of ideas that
fail they get ruled out and so then you
move on and the question is did some is
if you're going to introduce new physics
would it be before the time of the
cosmic microwave background would it be
after the time of the cosmic microwave
background and I think everybody agrees
that the later stuff is much harder to
work with and so I thought particularly
interesting I think is the idea of early
Dark Energy where you would have a
vacuum component to the universe that it
never dominates but it's important just
before the production of the the cosmic
microwave back background and it would
come in as a constant vacuum which
suddenly disappears at exactly the right
time and I'll tell you I saw that and I
thought oh my God that looks like a
phase transition to me yes so we've been
looking at first order phase transitions
as possible explanations and that would
be where you make bubbles of the the uh
the new phase kind of like boiling water
mhm and so this is yeah it's a
possibility that that would be an
explanation we called this one the chain
early Dark Energy mhm and yeah so that
got us interested more generally in
bubble collisions and how they might
actually show up in the grav the bubble
collisions lead to gravitational waves H
that you could see so there's a
prediction there and how would they
agree or or be in ttention or compete
with the primordial B mode polarization
that we're looking at the waves of
gravity that generate those phenomena no
they not in this not in the same
frequency range not um no not showing up
in the same way so could you see them
with like ligo or yes you could see them
with things like ligo or if they're
different not the ones for early Dark
Energy but more generally you could
nanograph is a has stochastic
gravitational waves that they've just
recently confirmed that's right and they
is that due to super massive black holes
colliding we don't know or actually
might what might fit the data better
would be bubble collisions from first
order phase transitions in the universe
and so we're we're exploring that
possibility when uh when I first saw you
know kind of the the initial data from
bicep back in 2014 2013 when we started
to have an inkling that we were on to
something it never really occurred to me
the kind of uproar that it would stir up
and of course I wrote about that in in
my first book losing the Nobel Prize but
so have I have I talked to you about the
what the Uproar it did to me I I I want
to talk because I remember we did I did
get an email from you and I did see
things like that around the time when
the rumors were kind of percolating
along with many of my friends and
colleagues so tell me about the upper I
actually haven't I haven't heard this
from from from the direct party involved
so please tell us Katee we have a model
called natural inflation yes it uses a
particle an Axion as the particle that's
responsible for
inflation and the the idea of using
axons for inflation I thought it was a
great idea back then because how else
are you going to explain this bizarre
situation where you have in it's a
really good idea and since then it has
been picked up by lots and lots of
people different variants of it the
original variant well we we had very
specific predictions for what it would
look like in CNB data and when this
original shortlived Discovery happened
it was a perfect match to the to the the
our Theory so I went through the roof
and I we all at at at M I was University
of Michigan we all got together in a
giant room to to talk about what the new
discoveries are and I was like going yay
so
uh but the basic idea still holds up
even though not that original simple
version uh explain for the audience I
may know I mean I have the most
brilliant audience in the known universe
I always say but but explain for my
audience that may not be familiar what
is an Axion uh and what does it have if
anything to do with inflation rather
than being a putative mechanism for Dark
Matter that's where they've heard about
it primarily on this channel so what is
an Axion and how can it be related to
inflation at all the original Axion was
the brainchild of Steven Weinberg and
simultaneously of Frank wilchek both
Nobel laurates Frank's been a GU and
though that idea would be a particle
that would solve problems in the theory
of strong interactions the and so that
is the Dark Matter candidate that people
are very excited about and looking for
however the word Axion I'm going to put
quotation marks around it now is used
more generally to you for anything that
has similar physics built into it so
what we need for inflation in particular
is we need this is a potential for the
vacuum energy which has it's a very very
flat potential and so it needs to be
very wide but then it needs to be short
you need to have six you have to have
lots and lots of e foldings of inflation
the universe has to inflate for a long
time but inflation also produces density
perturbations which we see in the CNB
and you can't overproduce those that's
right so the beauty of the Axion is that
there's a reason for two different scal
in the problem not most particle theory
you only have one and so the height and
the width would be the same but if we
use an quote unquote Axion modeling
modeled after the physics of the qcd
Axion we have a really good a literally
natural candidate for inflation so
that's what the ba that's what our basic
idea is it' be higher energy scales
important earlier in the in the universe
but it's the same on the on theoretical
grounds we're writing down the same
things I see now I don't have uh a
really strong opinion about the
following quote but I've heard it said
I'd love your reaction to it a theorist
only has to be correct once in her life
to make a career you outstanding career
an experimentalist only has to be wrong
once in his or her life to ruin his
career now I'm you know probably a
counter example to that what do you me
of that do theorists you know have a
propensity to kind of Swing for the
fences and and and if something sticks
then so be it but um uh but there's sort
of what I call lack of quality control
uh overabundance of theory or do you
think it's really more on a parody that
actually both experimentalists and
theorists both have to Grapple with
quality and quantity and and equal
measures what's your take on that on
that silly quote well let me start
talking about on the theory side because
something I know more about we have to
yeah we we whatever we do we can be
creative and that's what I really enjoy
doing sitting around the table batting
ideas around with people and then you
have a flash of insight wow we've got to
try this and it has to be consistent it
has to be self-consistent mathematically
it has to be consistent with all the
data that are out there and if you
violate any one of those things and you
if so if you make a big mistake and you
put that out in public you could really
hurt your career too just in the way you
said an experimentalist could so that's
not something I've ever done I've been
very I'm I'm I'm I think I'm known for
having a lot of ideas and I'm very
careful most of them die within 10
minutes or maybe within a week but
having them stick around for 30 years
that's pretty cool and I guess I
remember in grad school one of my
professors saying if you have a paper
that's still quoted 10 years later
you're doing well and by so I guess
that's the standard that I live by and
so I'm doing pretty
well my thumbs rather occupied right now
holding up good old Carl San but yours
is free to push that like button and
don't forget to subscribe it really
helps us with the algorithm now back to
the episode one of the my favorite
things about uh how you operate shall we
say are the the things that really speak
to me about about your your brand the
ktie freeze Katherine freeze brand is uh
that you love working with
experimentalists and in fact without you
the Simon Observatory may not have you
know gotten to the level that it's at
because you've been an instrumental no
pun intended uh supporter intellectually
and logistically financially etc etc how
do you choose of all the things that
your portfolio could allow as your I
mean you've had some just outstanding
you know successes in your career that
have led to tremendous leadership
opportunities for you how do you choose
as a leader where you're going to put
your institutions finances and the most
precious resource their intellectual
capital and attention how do you
allocate that as a leader well thank you
for the compliment and I have always
looked for physics that you can test and
I mean in my lifetime not 300 years from
now yeah so I work on dark matter that
you can test that is being tested we
were behind some of the tests that are
going on now yeah and ALS also on
inflation when we realize you can test
this and I that which is it's very not
just the idea of inflation overall but
individual models are testable because
of the density of perations because of
these primordial B modes that Sim's
Observatory is really going gunning for
and that is frankly why I got all
excited about CNB experiments because I
thought we're GNA get the B modes we're
going to prove that natural inflation is
right I was all into it and so then the
then the funny thing is you know there's
another piece of physics that I also
have on my very first paper ever mhm the
nut the bounds on neutrinos from
cosmology so the idea that you can go
after nutrino Mass with cosmology yes
and all of a sudden I was writing I I
hired a postto Martina gerbino she's
also a leader in Simon Observatory now
and we were writing a bunch of theory
papers and comparing to data and da d d
da guess who can go after that Simon's
Observatory so when all it
needs we can go after dark matter we can
go after so much Planet n all these so
that that was for that's why I really
wanted to get involved and started
hiring postdocs students lots of people
and most recently at UT Austin your
former postto Nick kitki doing great at
Tex picture of him here yeah good old
nicolitz I gave him a shout out on Joe
Rogan when I was on it I think I gave
you a shout I'm going to get you
connected to Joe Rogan and hopefully
fredman both of whom become uh I've
become friendly with um let's turn to
this back to this book uh in addition to
such cool topics as a DNA Dark Matter
detector which you and and and the
president of the Simons Foundation I
believe David spurgle worked on many
many a year ago uh the uh the aspects
for detecting dark matter as you say in
not only in your lifetime but in your in
your careers you know kind of um golden
years that we're you know I I won't say
golden years but just most productive
when you're making hay so to speak while
the sun is shining um I came away a
little bit pessimistic I mean the
subtitle is you know three parts dark
matter I came away a little bit
pessimistic from this book uh when I
read it um and I've Revisited it
recently let me move the CMB beach ball
so people can see it um that you know
perhaps uh it's just it's it's a long
shot but at least it's not as big a long
shot as dark energy you know when I sat
here when Adam Ree and I were sitting
there it just seems like there's almost
no hope for Dark Energy coined by as I
said Mike Turner who you'll see that
episode soon but even Mike you know
seems to agree that like we know almost
nothing about dark energy and where
where do you stand I mean I'm we're
going to get into Dark Matter dark stars
Etc what is dark the the other parts of
the cosmic cocktail what's your what
what do you make of that what the heck
is going on who ordered that drink dark
energy what the heck yeah so 95% of the
universe is the dark side and 70% is the
dark and
and you at this point you might as well
call it gobble because we know so little
it's and it's yeah well I will tell you
a story of my involvement so uh I
remember when people started the idea of
dark energy was named Dark Energy all of
a sudden and then all of a sudden we're
it's going to be parameterized in terms
of the equation of State W and I'm
sitting there thinking whoa wait a
minute The Observers are going to
specifically look for this one thing but
how do you know that's the right way to
parameterize it so I I was meeting in
Chicago I was out in the Halls all of a
sudden I had this inspiration wait a
minute what if you don't need any dark
energy at all what if it's only dark
matter and sorry only matter and photons
and so on so that's all there is there's
matter there's photons and there's
nothing else but the equations change
the equations are different and I'd been
working with a post talk Dan Chong on
extra Dimensions so there could be uh in
addition to our universe are
threedimensional Universe sitting as a
membrane in many other dimensions and
there could be another three-dimensional
membrane somewhere else and the the uh
the effects of this extradimensional
stuff is to change the equations
governing the evolution of our universe
so Einstein's equations as applied to
our universe the Freeman Freeman Roberts
and Walker equations there would be an
additional term okay and so we had talk
we had thrown around well we don't you
don't know what that term is but what if
it's such that it only becomes important
recently in the history of the universe
it causes acceleration just with matter
and R radiation photons and so on no
Dark Energy so I had that idea and I
probably foolishly called it Kardashian
cosmology so I I I still think that
could be true that the it's it's
Einstein's equations that need
a now since that time uh that was 2002
so then since that time a lot of people
have played a around with a lot more
sophisticated modifications of
Einstein's equations
uh dys formal gravity uh galileons D
most of those ideas have been ruled out
because gravity gravitons that are move
at the same speed as light pretty much
so those ideas have mostly died so that
I still think is an interesting
Direction but I kind of stopped working
on Dark Energy it's too hard yeah it it
seems just hopeless too hard and the
more as your colleague lak gr colleague
used to say the more you know we learn
about dark energy to paraphrase him he
said about the universe but he said uh
the more we learn about the universe the
more pointless it seems the more we
learn about Dark Energy it seems mostly
pointless um do you ever think about the
the um philosophical or the theological
even implications of your
research sure I think most of us in
cosmology thought about it it's part of
why we do what we do now the uh H the
the well there's the question is there
God or or is there not and how do we I
think cosmologists some are
automatically atheists no we're just
doing we're doing laws of physics we're
writing out equations and that's all
there is others are very religious and
well that tells you something that you
could you could this entire uh spectrum
is possible and still be doing cosmology
and so where do I stand on this I'm not
sure and how does it that you know
there's some questions like what is the
origin of time does that have something
to do is is that a physics question is
that a metaphysical question I in my
heart I believe all these things are
physics questions and that we'll we'll
get somewhere with them and similar to
the Multiverse what are your thoughts
there not crazy about it I feel like
it's chickening out not it's it's not
chickening out but you're not answering
the questions that you're supposed to be
answering which is why does do the
fundamental constants have the value
they do MH then yes I know if you change
the value of e the electric constant by
one tiny tiny bit then we all disappear
because our nuclei don't hold together
that's right yeah well that doesn't mean
that we happen to live in in in
somewhere in a Multiverse that has the
right value I don't believe I don't buy
that I'm sorry I want to know why it has
the value it
does yeah and now I think these are kind
of the questions that plague that should
plague people I find oftentimes my
students don't think about these things
that they got into cosmology because
they're really good at you know building
instrumentation working on dilution
refrigerators and vacuum systems or they
got into because they're really good in
theory and calculating and they love
doing homework problems as an
undergraduate and this got them into it
and they're creative and they want to
think about things but they tend not to
really address the you know as Roger
Penrose calls it the Mastadon in the
room which is you know what the heck is
going on with the origin of the Universe
on the other hand though Katie I wonder
how you react to this if I study you
know my biology colleagues you know that
gave me this brain and and everything
else like their job as biologist is not
to explain like the origin of life right
I mean some work on that but that's not
their job so why as cosmologists do we
think about understanding the origin of
the universe maybe that's a cop out I I
don't know if you want to react to to
that if not we can move on but um yeah I
just it's important to think about the
big picture topics um maybe I'll segue
into another Direction briefly and that
has to do with um you as an educator you
you're not only you know this world
famous uh theoretical physicist um you
know contributing for for in so many
different fields from machos dark matter
as today I learned about Axion and and
inflation um but you're also an educator
and I I think of you like that and I've
learned a lot from you not just from
your wonderful popular works and books
and appearances and so forth but also
from your your papers and and seeing you
lecture as we're going to be treated to
later today what's your philosophy as an
educator what what who do you look to do
you have Role Models mentors how does
someone become a teacher of the caliber
that you
exhibit I feel like as I as I teach as
as I get more and more experience I
relate to students better and better
and I even teach classes of nons right
now I'm teaching a non a class to
non-scientists really and it's maybe the
only class they're going to take in
anything related to physics or even the
hard Sciences sometimes and it's my job
to to get them excited that's I think
the main task I feel in in this
particular case and I've learned that if
I tell stories personal stories or
stories about Tao BR or whatever that
they they they have a lot of fun Galileo
oh there's Galileo okay so you tell
stories about people and you bring it
down to earth and they they really have
fun and they engage and who knows which
one of these is going to become a
politician who who votes on whether we
get funding or not so I feel like that's
one of my tasks my jobs and I also I've
always thought it was my job to Mentor
young women so I've always made a lot of
effort there initially it was really
assistant professors around the country
who would call me that we would talk and
uh I would advise them on you know when
when you have a job interview he's what
you should expect or whatever and so
I've always taken that very seriously I
think that's part of my teaching role Y
and I have I I had an undergraduate who
I thought I think she's outstanding so I
told her hey why aren't you applying to
grad school oh I hadn't thought of that
and so now she is you know was it Jan 11
your your Jan 11 was my very first
graduate student P guest yeah she was
she's pretty awesome phenomenal is love
Jen and she also exemplifies that trait
of doing giving back to the public as
well as to your colleagues and and to
your career and what you do well that's
another aspect of is not teaching but
Outreach so I think that's a really
important thing that we have to do and
so I give lots of public lectures um TV
radio panels and I think then podcasts
so I think all of this is really
important for us as scientists to reach
out to people who want to know what
we're doing yeah and pay our salary I
always joke you know if you worked at a
paperclip making factory and your boss
came in and said he what are you doing
today Brian and it's very very
complicated it's very Arcane and
Abstract you can't understand it boss
man so just leave it to the expert you
know they would you'd be fired the next
day and yet we expect the public to just
keep shoveling money towards us because
we're so smart uh and and sometimes I do
get this this comment um and I've gotten
a lot of heat from this on on Twitter
and other places where you should follow
Katie also Katie Freeze on Twitter but
the uh the notion I said that you know
it's it basically should be part of our
education Public Communication Outreach
and and I always hear oh no scientist
Sabina Hosten Felder many time guess no
scientists should just work on what they
do and we need people to and I said if
you you know if you want to continue to
to do what you do you have to at least
give some Roi return investment to the
public that pays your salary otherwise
you know not only jeopardizing you
specifically but the notion of
scientific education among the public
and she said oh it's too hard well okay
okay you know what's hard also Quantum
electrodynamics is really hard uh
working on inflationary potential is
really hard you weren't born knowing
that you learned how to do it so
anything you feel important you should
learn including communication I'm not
saying everyone should be me degrass
Tyson or ktie freeze but everybody
should have at least some exposure to
the so-called soft skills anyway I'll
give you retion when um I actually
advocated for a course where I mean if
you think about it the this is something
that's not taught so you're supposed to
go out into the world and you're going
to be judged immediately on how well do
you communicate what you do and you get
no no training no training I think
that's insane so I actually um did
create a course where people would give
talks at different levels and I brought
in speaking speaker speaking experts I
brought in breathing experts because all
of this matters can I take this c yeah
isn't that great and I created a um a
syllabus that actually went around the
country and other people used it but you
know in the end then you're told well
this isn't really hardcore and we really
need you to teach something more uh you
know subst more rigorous yeah so that
course kind of died but I think it's
it's I'm I'm really believ in it that's
what Janet told me to she said you know
when she was writing her first book they
were like don't do it you're not going
to get a job you know she wouldn't even
have her job at Barnard but um then her
second book or something they said well
we're not g you can write it uh we won't
punish you for it but we're not I had
the same thing I had a noal Laureate the
son of a NOA Laureate who's no longer
here so I can speak about him I love him
he loves me but but he used to say
things like you know we won't um we
won't hold it against you but we're not
going to give you any sabatical time
we're not going to do anything for any
of my books and so I've done it you know
in my summer you know when I'm not
getting paid by the university so that's
when I I'm asked would you like to write
another book and I'm like when am I
supposed to do that I mean it's tough
yeah especially with all the stuff that
you're juggling there let's get to the
to the really exciting stuff that just
you know as soon as I heard it I I
didn't even have to look they said that
Li Nets once got a paper and he was
asked to reviews about calculus or
something and the author was Anonymous
and he said it's Isaac Newton they said
how do you know and he said I know the
lion by his paw so I knew the lionness
you know when when I saw the you know
the dark stars when I saw J first of all
talk about this this is my brief that I
got from one of my sponsors ground news
dark stars are a proposed Concept in
which the first phase of Stellar
evolution in the universe is power
powered by Dark Matter heating instead
of nuclear fusion and then I read the P
proceeding the National Academy of
Science paper which is one not only does
Katie you know do the hardcore stuff but
your writing is phenomenal and I I did
you do like well let's get into that
later I don't want to keep you know keep
just just sing your praise I'll be here
all day but talk about dark stars are
formed at the centers of Proto galaxies
and the sufficient abundance of Dark
Matter servers or heat s where do these
things come from are they just like
let's fit the data or like have you been
thinking about these for a long time all
right 2007 wow I was a Miller professor
at Berkeley as a visitor and Doug spoar
former Michigan undergrad had started
grad school in Santa Cruz and said I
want to do a project with Katie free on
something to do with dark matter and
after many iterations of throwing the
ideas in the garbage because we were so
frustrated well something good came of
it and we involved Pao gondolo as well
and so the idea that the the very first
stars that form 200 million years after
the big bang inside these Proto galaxies
that will later merge together to make
galaxies and what what happens is you
have at that point the only thing
existing is hydrogen and helium from The
Big Bang you have the the you don't have
any other elements around yet so the
that that clouds of hydrogen start to
collapse inside the very centers of
these Proto galaxies there's molecular
hydrogen there's molecular hydrogen yes
M these clouds collapse start to
collapse and and in the standard picture
they get to get to be really really tiny
and then Fusion kicks in and and so on
and so forth and we just asked a simple
question yeah but at the center of Proto
galaxies there's a lot of dark matter
what does that do and the answer is that
the Dark Matter let's say it's some type
of dark matter that annihilates um um
these particles annihilate among
themselves such as weakly interacting
massive particles or some types of self-
interacting Dark Matter so if these if
the dark matter annihilates the
annihilation products they collide with
the hydrogen and they get stuck inside
this collapsing Cloud so all of a sudden
you're dumping all the energy that was
in the dark matter and you're dumping it
into the cloud as a heat source so we
realize okay well that's going to stop
that cloud from collapsing and then a
year later we realized oh my God it's an
actual star it's really satisfies the
four equations of Stellar structure it's
in hydrostatic equilibrium where gravity
is balanced by the pressure all because
we have this dark matter heating going
on and so forth and they become well
they initially start out about the mass
of the Sun but how weird they're 10 Au
in size 10 times the distance between
the Earth and the Sun big puffy cold
there's no Fusion there is not hot
anywhere Dark Matter Annihilation
doesn't care how hot it is MH and that
means that more mask can fall onto them
so they grow and grow and grow and they
can grow to become a million times as
massive as the sun and a billion times
as bright it's just I'm telling you it
took us a couple years to put all these
pieces together and at this point John
ma the Noel Laurette who put two Time
guest on the podcast yeah creator of the
James web Space Telescope and John
Gardner Pi of one of the instruments
they say to us come on this is a cool
idea tell us what we're going to see
what shall we look for and that was 2010
and so we we my grad student at the time
cosmin IL he did it he we figured out
okay what are the Spectra what are these
things going to look like and guessing
how many there could be that's hard but
so we went so we were waiting for the
data from the jwst and when it came out
we knew exactly what to do with it
because we were we had planned on this
you know so when when the data came out
um recently announced um there was a you
know claim that there were two galaxies
potentially that that might Harbor these
objects 10 Au it sounds big but you know
red shift of 11 it's infinitesimal at
least small so how can you you know how
can you be sure how how could one verify
or refute that these are these galaxies
themselves are Harbor these massive dark
stars within them well one Dark Star
would be as bright as an entire galaxy
containing a bnch a lots of smaller
stars and the the way to tell the
difference will be well let me you know
let me back up jwst has 700 objects from
potentially from the early Universe
probably but you're not really sure
until you get Spectra the brightness at
different uh frequencies and so they had
at the time we wrote our paper they may
have more now but there were nine with
Spectra and that that were AB absolutely
confirmed as being early Universe
objects MH and of those nine five were
had publicly available data and so we
looked at those and four in particular
interesting the J a objects James web
extra
Galactic I don't know survey GS z11 d0
that's well yeah these are the these are
so of those of those four objects that
had Spectra three of them are consistent
with being dark stars and what I mean by
that so the Spectra spectrum of any Star
it's a black body it goes up and it goes
back down in a very well- defined way
and Our Stars would be made only of
hydrogen and helium so that's all you
would see information about that's all
that you would see whereas these
repeating galaxies they have also later
generations of stars in there so you
would you that's processed so you'd see
carbon nitrogen I don't know neon
whatever and so down the road when we
get clean
Spectra then we'll know which which it
is how can you differentiate so I would
imagine uh these could be confused with
other objects that are also to my
knowledge not discovered but are part of
the panoply of research portfolio for
web which is called population
am I right that we have never discovered
something that we know for sure is
population 3 and then two how would you
distinguish a dark star from a
population 3 object so the population 3
objects uh were the when I was telling
this picture the collapsing hydrogen
Cloud clouds and that that is the
standard formation of the population
three stars and they are hot they have
Fusion so they can't grow very large
they can grow about to 500 times as
massive as the sun we're talking about a
million times as massive so they're so
our guys are a hell of a lot brighter
right I see so that would be a way to
disting in fact the only so the only way
that we're really going to figure out
what's going on is not probably not the
current objects but many I mean James
Webb is just getting started and so
there are there will be many more
objects coming in and some of those will
be magnified by lensing in other words
they'll look brighter and you'll have
more information because there's stuff
in front of them that that makes that
amplifies the signal if you have just an
ordinary like line an alpha cloud or
just some primordial hydrogen Cloud um
molecular hydrogen cloud or or other
configuration can you still form these
dark star like could there be some
forming in the Milky Way or somewhere or
they only form in the primordial
Universe they they're uh as soon as you
get other chemistry going it's it's it's
different so we're talking about the
hydrogen and helium only only right so
you couldn't do it from pre-process well
I mean no not you can't do it from
processed stuff but what if there's some
void that hasn't had any action that's
right that's and so maybe somewhere in
there're still sitting uh there s
there's still a few forming in there but
so we wouldn't expect to see one
floating by in the Milky Way or
something right I say no too
bad um so yeah so these objects have you
know really captivated the attention in
the media um along with Reuters picked
it
upter picks it up everybody picks it up
Scientific American yeah front page
article in new s it was incredible yeah
it's beautiful we'll show a cover the
cover article of it on our uh on the
footage if you're watching on YouTube
where you can find me uh Dr Brian keing
but also find Katie on Twitter and and
many other interviews that I've done
with her and she's been featured before
um so I want to talk about another thing
that might be concomitant with this
discovery and this is the so-called
claim that is uh proferred about the
same media in some circumstances
unfortunately uh New Scientist or fizz.
org you know that the either the Big
Bang never happened oh I think I know
what's coming yeah or the universe is 26
ion years old not 13 billion years old
um including by gentleman rajes Gupta
who regenda Gupta who's in Ottawa who's
I've been in contact with but maybe
he'll come on the podcast and come to
visit us but anyway tell us what is this
connection what do you make of the these
claims uh because I'm old enough to
remember in 1996 or whatever when Hubble
deepfield came out and you heard the
same kinds of things these galaxies are
too mature to have spiraling arms and
and so forth and have this Grand Design
the universe must be much older in fact
it must be infinitely old or Eternal
what do you make of these claims why are
they so eye-catching and clickbaity for
for the uh for the media well I mean
sure it would be exciting if we'd been
getting everything wrong all along but
you know what I don't think we have
Brian I'll turn to you you're the CMB
guy you tell me what's the age of the
universe every piece of data you've ever
looked at right well so the claims are
the following so you have to in my mind
the part of education is you should be
able to steal man or steal woman the the
the opponent so they'll say there are
other explanations for the CMB there are
things that we don't understand in the
CMB that need to be explained and
including like how do these pertubations
get there how do these how did it get to
be so thermal um yeah and um and and
then other things can be explained by
phenomena as I said that are more well
formed like plasmas are much more
familiar than say inflation or scaler
field that we only know one example of
the higs BOS and again I'm just
bolstering my opponent's Viewpoint right
so they'll say they are these props and
they they'll say that you know light can
lose energy it can become red shifted
and it can make the appearance of of all
these things but the worst thing is that
these Galaxy size tests fail the
standard uh in you know expansionary
hypothesis they're inconsistent the
Tolman test they fail the so-called
tollman test and the only way around
those Tolman tests that the Galaxy Size
Doesn't decrease with distance according
to these people is that you know the
universe is much much older than we see
it and so the light has gotten tired by
its travel some mechanism they don't
explain and or the fundamental constants
are changing as you said you know
Alpha's changing what have you or you
know um or some hybrid so anyway
obviously the CNB tells us a lot it
doesn't tell us about time equals zero
it only tells us only tells us 380,000
years after the big bang uh but they're
lacune in the Big Bang model that's the
nature of science so what these people
attempt to do is say these um these
these flaws lead to a consideration that
maybe the Big Bang is wrong okay that
being said what could or could not these
dark stars do to alleviate these
hypothetical tensions between the age
problem I had Alison kpatrick on uh from
Kansas um she was the one who's quoted
like astronomers are panicking you know
because that J the web shows these
spiral galaxies so that is a concern I I
have my own take on that um the CNB is
just positive in my opinion but that the
Big Bang happened but these Galaxy
formation models they seem to require
some maturation beyond the 13.8 or
Beyond 300 million years after after the
formation of the Light Elements so tell
us you're the expert in these things so
how could dark stars alleviate or not
this problem quote unquote of mature
early galaxies so another way to talk
about so the standard model of a
cosmology the 70% Dark Energy da the
Lambda CDM model of cosmology three
parts people yeah three parts Dark
Matter people have done simulations of
structure formation and you have certain
predictions for how many objects you
should see and and and so forth and so
these these bloated things that they're
seeing early on where this there's all
how what faction of the barans of the
universe have to go in to create one of
these things I have two answers to that
one is well we're very happy if some of
those are actually dark stars so let's
take away some of the big beasts that
you don't know how to explain well we do
so that is I was actually thinking of
mentioning that okay and and then and
actually secondly there's also the
Edington bias and I don't know what role
that plays in this this is an
observational bias okay if you have
there there are let's say lots more
faint objects than than bright ones then
it's more likely that a that a faint one
looks bright than the other way around
so in terms of basian it's not a flat
prior there's a you need to take that
into account I'm not sure so people some
people have done that with with these
with these galaxies so that could be
part of the explanation but I'm I'm
sticking I'm sticking to my guns I want
some of them to be dark stars that would
be that would be phenomenal we'll take
some we'll be the uh podcast that had
you on when uh I want to close out
because we have to get you over to the
uh medical school to give your a
colloquium that is so uh so uh desirable
for millions of people to go watch and
maybe uh maybe eventually we'll get a
recording of it now Brian can we have a
sip of this before we do anything else
absolutely let's for let's get these
Irish up these coffees um I want to ask
you uh just two last questions one is is
about your uh pedagogical expectations
so I have a rule for my students
including one you're going to meet in a
minute uh as he uh escorts you to get
your uh your laptop and that is that my
experimentalists they need to know
Theory they don't need to do Theory they
need to know Theory they need to know it
as well as an incoming theoretical
physics graduate student sounds good not
required to do it um and then obviously
they have to be World expert in the
experimental aspects of the polar bear
Simons Z Simons Z they need to know that
way better than I do because they're
interacting with it you know I already
have my PhD they don't right um what and
I call that the experimental minimum in
deference to our good friend Lenny susin
who talks about the theoretical minimum
he means something else by it but uh I
want to ask you what is the theoretical
minimum like you have a theor new Fresh
Off thee booat grad student she's coming
to Texas she's working with you what
does she need to know about experiments
if anything oh oh about experiments I
thought you were going to say what what
courses does does she need to
I mean I assume that that that's
relatively all right let's assume
everybody's taken the same courses
including
Quantum graduate cosmology and took as a
high school student no didn't you start
college at like 15 or 16 partly because
my high school had no physics at all so
it was the other way around but anyway I
survived
it so I talk to experimentalists all the
time it's part of your brand oh you have
to you have to so they have to yes I
make them do that how do do you
instantiate that how do you make them do
it um how do you get them interested for
one thing we have our in our Weinberg
seminars we have experimentalists talk
to us and so that I that I think is
really helpful and who did we hire
recently at uh at UT Austin we can't
just lot of we we we have to hire
experimentalists so we hired your your
former posto Nikiski at UT Austin and we
all go to Weinberg lunch together every
Tuesday and we talk to each other so
that's I think really really important
that that so that's Synergy and we have
the astronomy Department in the same
building you take the all in the same
elevator and so we we we talk to
astronomers up there as well we also
talk to we have dark matter
experimentalist we have to talk to each
other yeah that's phenomenal yeah um
last question has become kind of a
boilerplate uh question that I've asked
people uh Chang them since you were last
on the podcast and that has to do with
um a quote from Sir Arthur C Clark you
know that the uh the into the impossible
name into the impossible ITI for those
of you who didn't know that uh arthury
Clark did a lot of things he invented
the term podcast un un unintentionally
he did well yeah in 2001 A Space Odyssey
you remember that Dave is going to back
in the shuttle to put it back in the
space station and he asks how 9000 open
the pod bay doors and the Pod became
known as this you know supporter of
information and life assistance and then
Steve Jobs and one of members of his
team took that idea and made the iPod
after which the name the iPad after the
how 9000 you know scene in in 2001 Space
Odyssey and then podcast grew out of the
iPod oh you're kidding so that's where
it all arthury Clark also said the only
way of determining the limits of the
possible is to go beyond them into the
impossible so that's the name of this
podcast but he said another thing and I
think I asked you a couple of uh related
questions but I've since added a fourth
law of his he said the following when an
um I'm not going to say elderly I I
cannot say elderly when I when I look at
you I cannot say elderly but he said
something like that he said when an
elderly but distinguished scientist says
something is possible he and I'm going
to say she is very much certainly
correct that it's possible but when he
says something is impossible he is very
likely to be wrong I'm not calling you
elderly I'm not but I am calling you
distinguished I want to use that and ask
you what have you been wrong WR about
what have you changed your mind about
what has surprised you that you knew ear
I'll give you one tell me I remember
being at conferences and talking to some
brand new graduate student who wrote on
napkin he writes Lambda equals zero and
we all agreed the cosmological constant
aha that's obviously zero because there
are already observers saying well wait a
minute There's Something Fishy going on
which we could explain if we had a
cosmologic we had a cosmological
constant in there and I we all thought
on the theorist we were like so so sure
it was not there we were wrong we were
wrong there's Dark Energy well I don't
know if it's cosmological constant but
there's I don't know if it's dark energy
but there's something weird going on so
we were just wrong dead wrong wow yeah
well Katie Freeze it's such a delight to
have you back on the podcast especially
in person it's been a little while we
did a lovely event in upen a couple
years back for our books and and that
was a delight that was fun and uh just
can't wait to to be now that you're
closer and you know closer than Sweden
or Michigan now you're in Sunny Texas
where we'll have to get you on the Pod
circuit as well but this is we knew you
when we knew you when we only had you
know a couple hundred thousand
subscribers and followers Katie Freeze
uh keep being an inspiration it's
experimentalist keep uh supporting the
efforts as a leader and never never ever
give up that wonderful brand that is
just so uniquely you and you you're a
mentor to me I we're similar in age so
it's not like like oh you're I knew you
when I was a baby but um but you have
such a um such an effect on
collaborations and you're the the glue
that's that helps keep us together and
Thrive so thank you so much Katie oh
thank you Brian it's been great let's
get you to your to your lecture okay
thanks a lot see you next time on into
the impossible with Brian keing your
fearful host and uh remember subscribe
find Katie on Twitter and find her
website as well and we'll have links to
her papers and the the uh New Scientist
article down below thanks a lot we're
out